the Newark Police Department over the
last 12 years has made extraordinary
progress in reducing crime in New York
it started 20 25 years ago an idea that
called CompStat which was the idea that
turned all the data that we have about
crime transparent let us see an infinite
detail where it's happening who's doing
it gives us the opportunity to then
manage Crime Control very precisely and
very and very effectively and move our
resources where crime was and in fact
bring it down in extraordinary ways but
what we also saw was that over these
last 12 years the move to crime control
costs the New York Police Department
citizens support it costs the New York
Police Department the support of
citizens for an incredibly important
mission which was Crime Control we know
that it's possible to have a great crime
control and strong citizen support and
we know that is possible as well to
truly engage police officers in that
work when you have those three things
moving together and when you keep your
eye not only on citizen support and
workforce engagement and Crime Control
but finally then on outcomes for
neighborhoods and we see we measure our
success by whether people are playing in
parks where their kids can walk to
school safely then we'll have a success
in a way that we've never had before it
we've lost a large segment of New
Yorkers we know that we can get them
back and we need to and we need to in
order to do that we'll be successful
with crime control when we are able to
mobilize all segments of New York and
support of it if we can't then we're not
going to have the information that we
need we're not going to have a support
that we need where today's witness would
won't come forward tomorrow if they
don't see the results so that we're in a
new world today where
some of the traditional tools of law
enforcement have been taken away from
the New York Police Department by the
courts stop and frisk we see the effect
on the street corners and public housing
trespass laws have been a very effective
tool for law enforcement because we
don't need to ask permission we are the
we are the the agents of the public
housing we can we use trespass summonses
for that kind of control even marijuana
stops have been a way of control those
three important control tools are now
changing for the New York Police
Department and we have to find new ways
to assure safety and security for
citizens to do that we will need to
engage and to do that we will need to
understand far better than we do the
sources of citizen support and to see
far better than we ever have before
crime as it as it begins to to emerge we
know now that some of the the hardest
press precincts and boroughs of New York
that crews small groups of kids
teenagers have come together you know
hundreds of crews that are responsible
for a great deal of the gun violence in
New York by hearing them speak watching
them speak looking at them on social
media we understand who is doing a lot
of the who's causing a lot of the damage
in the city and we've been able to
address that not by hammering entire
communities but by precision targeting
these young people and no not all of
them were bad boys and bad girls a lot
of them are good kids just getting mixed
up with bad stuff and instead of
hammering whole communities begin to
work very surgically that's the future
of policing in New York and it's a
future that's data-driven that looks for
the support of communities by by
building up our contact in our
engagement by social media by using
social media also to understand the ebb
and flow of crime and disorder in
communities using it appropriately and
safely this is the new wave of policing
in New York it's the next generation
where we measure our success not simply
by CompStat Crime Control numbers but by
Crime Control plus citizen support plus
workforce engagement plus neighborhood
outcomes and we're now able to measure
all of those in ways that we never have
before we plan to so that we as we
achieve Crime Control we lift support
and we lift a workforce engagement and
we achieve great results for
neighborhoods that's really our goal and
I think what we can do next